Now Matt you seem fine and as you can
tell I'm fine uh I am well I'm just in
general like Baseline you're not no no I
know Baseline I'm not fine but I have my
chemistry has not been altered Sonia you
were three sheets to the wind I'm not
three states
I'm just like I'm drinking a little
quicker than I usually normally do just
because it's a great drink and you don't
taste you can't tainted no it's a great
drink and you can't taint it now
Rising slogan
every liquor company wants now every
Spirits company Ryan Reynolds is calling
right now to say hey can I use that oh
for my gin it's a great drink and you
can't taint it you can't taint it the
flavor's so good you can taint it
your teeth can taste it okay Sana
please there's a danger at some point
but you'll become unprofessional okay
drunk Sona is Funk Sona it's good all
right no I'm fine I'm in a good place
she's in a really good place now we're
good we're looking after the kids
tonight
I don't know uh
were we were before the show when you
and I were down the street you had a
lovely conversation I think your
husband's there and I believe your
father's there as well no my in-laws are
watching the babies and Tack is at his
karate practice has he ever used karate
in real life has he ever been attacked
by a bunch of ninjas in the street okay
you don't I'm asking you real quick and
that's a real question I weigh in on
this I rode in with Sona today and I was
riding in the passenger seat and in the
like dashboard there was a solid block
of mahogany wood and I went what's this
for and she said sometimes when tack
drives he just puts that on his lap and
punches it yeah oh my God conditioning
I'm wondering like have you ever seen it
in action I mean I've seen him do karate
when I've gone to like exhibitions and
stuff but if you're talking about are we
walking down a dark alley and someone
jumps out and is like give me all your
money and then he's like
he doesn't say chop chop why not yeah
it's not you don't you're supposed to
karate is not saying yeah you're
supposed to say chop yeah chop chop chop
my point is there's a part of me that's
a little curious yeah I kind of want to
attack your husband just to see what
would happen he would brutally beat you
do you really think so I also don't
think you need any karate trainings
what if we went and did a home invasion
tonight at their house yeah so when he
was he was you know what's really great
mock home invasions is a prank yeah in
California that's a wonderful idea hey I
got a better idea let's do that in Texas
let's go do some mock home invasions
just for fun and see how that goes oh
wow they have a lot of guns their guns
have guns yeah
town and I went to go get a weapon to
protect myself and he had a sword so I
had I was sleeping and I had a sword
next to me the whole time but if anyone
ever broke into my house I wouldn't know
what to do what did I tell you earlier
today that there's a certain friend of
mine who's also known he's in the public
eye who regularly gifts me weapons yeah
we're talking about Joel McHale yes Joel
McHale every Christmas gives me a deadly
weapon but it's all they're all kind of
interesting like weird blades and crazy
samurai swords and a mace he gave me a
modern day mace like that you could you
know ball with spikes yes exactly so I
have all this stuff in my house so uh
Crooks robbers and Ruffians beware I'm
armed with a Joel McHale Armory of
stilettos blades Bashers and Smashers oh
look our pizzas are ready oh thank God
just in time for me to stop this crazy
monologue is going nowhere oh what do
you oh that growth
one of the pizzas looks like it needs
surgery is that my guy yeah that looks
amazing
thank you so much so I just take the
whole thing oh my God that looks really
nice Pizza up all right sauna just take
it easy I'm gonna marry this pizza in a
courthouse wedding yeah I want to write
this pizza a letter stating my
intentions and hoping I get a
affirmative response
that's very good let's hear you chew
them
let's hear you chew them Eduardo
oh God help me that's delicious that is
very good gentlemen okay GG Chris this
is really good thank you you're welcome
this is I mean
I love pizza I love pizza I love pizza
all day I can't believe your songwriting
career never took off
um
guys this is cooked the exact correct
amount time thank you yeah chewy but um
not too crispy I like it a little chewy
huh yeah you heard me well I I said
chewy which was a good thing and then
you said I like it chewy and that's like
me saying you know my life she's very
pretty I like pretty women
what's wrong with pretty women
no one was disagreeing with you weirdo
are there napkins look just just lay off
okay I'll get you something no hang up
hang out here uh listen my
congratulations to you and uh to uh we
got to give it up for the pie this is
amazing pie it's not us yeah
DG and Chris thank you guys thank you
guys can I do this if I don't know how
to make pizzas yes okay yeah 100 there's
a little learning curve I wouldn't throw
a party and start making pizzas for 30
people do it by yourself do a couple
trial runs and then you can do that
should I open up his tries you'll be an
expert I did that I opened a pizza
restaurant and I've never made a pizza
before and I did it
in New York and have like a very intense
area where there's a lot of competition
and I had never tried it before and
guess what the place failed immediately
um devouring this pizza all right stop
it I really are this is guys this is
really terrific thank you and soon
you'll hear in the next installment the
juices in my stomach working away
boo yeah this is a celebrity scoop
laughs